III 2017 an absolute perfect event now
normally I don't care about III I've
been let down too many times too many
times have I watched this [ __ ] and I get
so hyped for a game and and then it just
kills it I worry about like
disappointing people you know did the
game just crash the ps4 it is completely
crashed sorted I found that it's so much
more satisfying to be pleasantly
surprised by a game rather than just
bitterly disappointed hype is dangerous
hyper kills good games if you see a
cinematic trailer and you think all that
game looks cool you better run run real
fast cuz most likely the game will be
[ __ ] wow wow wow wow
but now I've learned to appreciate III
for a different reason the cringe
compilation and God thank you thank you
for this year it was beautiful and
really good it was it was spectacular
but it got better as time went oh oh yes
god bless you god bless see now don't
get me wrong I think it's cool that AEA
brings in influencers to promote games
but isn't Jesse a prank channel dude I
don't know whatever like I don't care
but at the same time I could have been
there actually you know what that's
pregnant never mind never mind never
mind what up guys thank you for having
me ei if you guys don't know who I am my
name is jesse wellens and i am a YouTube
creator so I am here to I have me still
here hahaha oh this is painful this one
is so hard to watch I like Jesse don't
get me wrong I understand the pressure
and apparently the teleprompter [ __ ]
that but that now you need for speed
payback if you guys didn't know you
could shoot a back I'm but um you know
what I'm just gonna let this one play
because I just remember I had to a thing
but I'll be right back just to keep
playing in it yeah it's good game but I
also decide I'm a YouTube creator deep
speed Tabak coming out I got my blue
mark its executive producer here is
Marquess in the game again for having me
oh my god I met Jesse he's a cool dude
like I'm the kind of guy that will [ __ ]
this up I don't know what happened Jesse
amen
hey hey hey men why am i judging other
people publicly I forgot what was Jessie
again I forgot
I am a YouTube creator okay okay wait
where are you again I forgot I am here
okay but I also decide I'm a YouTube
creator that's right he was you to crash
forgot [ __ ] okay cool
now of course after this conference
polygon with the first to point out to
attack influencers as they do they keep
attacking good people like myself with
these what what what wow disgusting
claims games or companies can't ignore
YouTube or the hope of reaching a
broader audience but if you don't
understand what the talent they're
paying can and can't do well and plan
accordingly it's going to be awkward
well god damn it that actually makes
sense polygon god damnit this doesn't
set my narrative damn you polygons I was
expecting you to write a bunch of [ __ ]
they give influence of swag bags
disgusting why don't I go to e3 I could
have gotten a swag bag this is got yeah
I'm an influencer I could have gone one
of those swag bags makes me angry video
games is a wonderful thing alright let's
get into some more beautiful moments I
try to collect some of my favorite we
just disabled a moving truck with a
grenade while jumping off a horse
incredible that is incredible incredible
I feel bad I think that's the reason the
compassion is a important element of a
cringe I hope you guys don't think I'm
just judging all these people feel for
these people I bleed for these people
because I am these people but ten times
worse incredible it hurts it really
hurts to see this I just wish no one was
socially awkward and we could all just
live our life normally but in reality
interacting with other people it's too
high
I'm Janina gavankar and I play commander
idler co-leader of the Inferno squad a
Star Wars Battlefront - I don't know
what you make even just an awkward smile
and the whole world will see that oh
there's so many ways to [ __ ] up
players like sterling you saw in the
video how hands are a little bit this
guy needs to go and go to jail
someone needs to send this man to prison
I'm sorry players like sterling you saw
in the video
how's your hands a little bit but the
guy in the meadow I wonder what he's
thinking about this moment it's the kind
of moment there is so much going on you
don't really know what to Crane about
there's just some like a goodie bag of a
cringe oh you don't know where to place
it but can I get three oh yes on three
one two three like do you cringe about
there is they who yes you created this
guy being way too into it you creatures
these two people trying to kiss but it's
like what are you doing ah and to talk
about this unexpected encounter it is my
great honor to welcome a very special
guest someone I truly admire please
[Music]
Oh hold up hold up hold sim in on that
picture zoom in on that picture is that
is that a rabbit peach taking a selfie
right there whoa I'm breaking up right
that's right
I find someone else raving rabbit peach
selfie person you have reached a number
that has been disconnected I gotta say
Beyond Good and Evil does look pretty
[ __ ] cool fun a poquito but you know
it's a cinematic trailer so remember
remember what I told you I want city
back so welcome to system three our
story takes place before the birth of
Jade in a multi-ethnic multicultural
human society in a distant solar system
a multi-ethnic multicultural society
that's pretty cool
but what is the country students such a
crime-ridden dystopia enslave our
corporations Wow whoa weird coincidence
hey you racist piece of [ __ ] how dare
you okay I'm sorry about Edgar racist
[ __ ] dog hey I'm Charlie five looks
pretty cool what started out as a wild
idea on paper has now turned into a
groundbreaking one of a kind came called
a way out take a look what's your plan
uncharted five you have a problem I love
that Africa Africa Africa Africa just
who the [ __ ] you afro girl nice and
drink Ifrah girl everyone that's race
come on shut shut up shut your [ __ ]
mouth
remember when the valve try to make you
pay for mods remember that introducing
creation club well I guess but that's
tougher guy I'm playing with the Wounded
Warrior she was kind to Travis you
superior tactic to get herself on in
there she's got to take the win let's
move on to the next arena there were
following bloody barrel to delete you
players are we gonna get runner router I
was standing here awkwardly hey everyone
at e3 I'm standing here awkwardly
yelling for no reason
wearing a yellow t-shirt that this
gameplay is really exciting I think at
least I don't know it wouldn't be e3
without unnecessary dance segments
[Music]
this is why I love video game follow
Jake on Twitter it's at Salomon Jake
following say hello and tell him you're
proud to be a follower yeah he's [ __ ]
plug his Twitter holy [ __ ] he got six
followers man I got to go to e3 next
year and plug my Twitter god damn it
looks like on X bone what Xbox one egg
stop haha
he said X bone X bone what Xbox one
explain what why am I here
so then you had an announced last week
for far cry 5 that went great one of the
things I've noticed is that every time
you go out on stage you look super calm
does it get easier year after year nope
not even a little
I'm dying on the inside you to rotate
the reports check it out but a bull
shark moose elk we also have my boy
Dartmouth aka Bank myth he will be
playing as well Sean is pretty cool
right and I am pretty cool right Jesus
thanks audience oh man I love e31 mate 1
million dollars alright million dollar I
heard that before
1 million truth 1 million troops
Wow all jokes aside I think e3 is pretty
cool it's always fun to see what the
next game is going to be I think the
main reason that turns me off is the
hype but also the way they look at you
as a consumer it feel so off how they
look at you I think the shows pretty
well
[Music]
made deadlier with every single match we
achieved
we rise we want to die it reminds me of
those gaming t-shirts that has some some
[ __ ] [ __ ] on them like video game
doesn't make us violent lagged us
warning game mode activated but that was
one publisher that saw the light and saw
through all the corporate currency
bullish a devolver robbed the servers
are full of news with the vulgar common
created content it is you the player who
is in control and it is available now
already on every major forum message
board and life
give everybody ladies and gentlemen what
we have shown you here today is only the
beginning so there you have it III 2017
what was your favorite [ __ ] what games
are you excited about okay am I excited
about I don't play game kings are for
nerds
[Music]